what's been the toughest loss of your
career that you remember would that be
the um
the world championship match oh yeah for
sure can you take game aids in 2016. and
who was it against against karjakin in
in new york uh can you take it through
the story of that game um where were you
uh
before that game in terms of game one
through seven
yeah so game one and two not much
happened uh games three and four i was
winning in both of them and um
normally
i should definitely converted both
i couldn't partly due
to
good defense on his part but mostly
because
i just
i messed up
and then after that
games five
six and seven not much
happened i was getting impatient that
at that point um so for
game eight i was probably ready to take
a little bit more risks than i i had
before
which i guess was insane because i knew
that
he couldn't beat me unless i beat myself
like he wasn't strong enough to outplay
me
and that was leading to impatience
somehow and impatience no because i knew
that i was better yeah i knew that i was
better i knew that i just needed to win
one game and then the match is over yeah
you